est-ce que vous avez des problèmes de
connexion internet à la maison parce que
vous n'avez pas de fille parce que vous
avez une adsl me laissait un petit peu
mauvaise ou alors est-ce que carrément
vous n'avez pas du tout des connexions
internet à la maison parce que vous
n'êtes pas souvent parce que ces deux
résidences secondaires parce que c'est
pas possible parce que je ne sais pas
quoi
et du coup c'est un peu la galère alors
justement j'ai la solution pour vous
aujourd'hui c'est une vidéo qui réalise
un partenariat avec tes pelli qui vous
propose un produit cool un produit
intéressant qui va vous aider vous
permet de vous solutionner la
problématique d'internet à la maison
quand la fibre n'est pas là quand l'adsl
n'est pas à la hauteur
eh bien il vous reste la kadji la 4g
plus et croyez-moi ça ça peut être
vraiment très intéressant
[Musique]
il
non
[Musique]
c'est vrai ok je sais des fois on a des
problèmes internet avant moi à la maison
pour tout vous dire ici j'ai pas la
fibre le cas de la fibre est posée dans
le jardin les mecs ont pas fini le
boulot ça fait des mois que ça dure
c'est une galère absolue
j'ai l'adsl très mauvais très très très
très mauvais et du coup lorsque je vous
envoie une vidéo par l'agaci de course
que je plaide la vidéo par adsl sur
youtube et bien je les crois peu près
trois heures quand je suis au studio à
paris mais allez on va dire quoi 56
secondes ça ça marche très bien ça
marche très fort mais ici là c'est une
galère absolue du coup qu'est ce que je
fais je passe par la 4g et il ya
notamment cette petite boîte qui est
vachement intéressant de tp link alors
ça c'est un modem un modem-routeur là
s'appelle le hsg pas si vous voyez bien
archers nr 603 des tice marché est merci
sens qui vous permet justement
solutionner pas mal de problèmes les
caddys âge sont très claires très simple
je vous lis effectivement pas de fibre
adsl mauvaise ou alors carrément vous
avez une maison à la campagne vous
n'êtes pas relié à internet
ou alors vous n'y allez pas tout le
temps c'est une résidence secondaire et
bien lorsque vous y allez vous voulez
tout simplement pouvoir effectivement le
connecter très facilement l'idée de
cette petite note là c'est en fait ce
modem qui est ici là la réunion très
sympathique vous allez prendre une carte
sim qu'au cours restent là toi vous
allez prendre une petite carte sim 4g
vous allez venir à l'insérer et vous
montrer comment savoir vous allez voir
c'est très simple très pratique ça
marche super bien vous allez là m et
cette petite chose là va nous permettre
de diviser votre signal internet à la
maison
effectivement en wi fi ou alors
carrément ici en ethernet pour
différentes solutions première chose
qu'on va se faire plus tôt je vous
montre le produit bon c'est pas un
produit vous avez souvent regardé il va
être posé quelque part il va à temps il
va prendre la poussière de son côté mais
il va servir à vous rendre la vie plus
facile il vous permettre de vous
connecter
voilà le produit regardez-moi ça comme
cet oubli j'aime bien il a un seul
défaut principal et c'est qu'en fait il
aime bien la poussière des on voit un
concours ici aux reflets il aime bien la
poussière il est trés électrostatique
donc tout ce que vous allez avoir petite
trace petit cochonneries et bien ça va
être dessus là il faut vraiment passer
le chiffon pourront le faire parce que
même à la main voyez c'est pas ils
paieraient pas pratiquement c'est pas
très grave ce n'est pas un objet de
décoration vous dans un placard y bouge
pas
antenne fac viala qui viennent se visser
s'installer pour venir diffuser le
signal en termes de connectique c'est
très simple vous avez ici il ya de quoi
devenir le médecin secteur avec son
petit bloc de charge qui se trouve là
bon là il ya rennes absolument dingue ça
ça marche est très simple un petit
bouton pour venir l'allumé pour
l'éteindre vous avez 4lan dans la
dernière qui fait lan wan ça c'est cool
le bouton wps le reset de quoi qui
vivotent wi fi home of ici vous insérez
votre carte micro sim
ici pas de nanos things may adaptateur
avec je vais vous montrer comment ça
marche pratique voyez après c'est très
simple c'est très sommaire vous le
prenez vous le branchez une fois qu'il
est configuré qui est dans un coin
il fait le job tout seul ça deviens
complètement invisible quelqu'un comme
moi qui trempe c'est pas hyper évident
en fait ce qu'il faut vous fassiez sais
que vous le prenez j'ai un petit scotch
qui fournit avec ça je ne sais pas hyper
pratique d'avoir ce petit scotch mais
bon ça fait le taff 1 mais j'aimerais
passer quelque chose de plus simple vous
prenez votre carte vous la posez vous
venez là scotchées au dos histoire que
ça bouge pas que vous l'ayez comme ça
une fois qu'elle est posée quelle est
scotché vous emmenez votre routeur et là
vous venez lacéré ici il vous montre
bien la forme vous prenez vous le mettez
comme ça vers le bas et tac
elle est bloquée elle a serré ça
s'écroule ensuite c'est très simple eh
bien on fait quelque chose de simple on
prend on va débrancher se branchent lui
sur ce secteur je prends tu as regardé
il va la power up salut ils activent le
wifi ans qui va se connecter directement
4g pour le truc c'est qu'il faut
toujours revenir un peu le nettoyer
parce que ça laisse vraiment des traces
et si je vous fais un truc beau la vidéo
d'art garder je prends ma petite
chiffonnette voyez c'est ce qu'il faut
que vous fassiez chez vous parce qu'au
bout d'un moment c'est un peu attrape
poussière bon ok c'est pas très fière
une fois de plus n'est pas un objet de
décoration vous allez mettre en avant
dans votre salon et que tout le monde va
admirer mais faut quand même passé un
petit coup de chiffon net si on voit que
ça brille
on l'a donc un modem routeur 4g
catégorie 6 wifi 5 qui vous permet
d'avoir une connexion internet jusqu'à
300 mégabits par seconde
ça c'est vraiment le gros maximum s'il
use d'une zone qui marche vraiment bien
après ça va dépendre subtilement de la
couverture 4g là où vous êtes
il ya une possibilité vous verrez c'est
que si acadienne est pas bonne ça va
vous switchez en 3g là ça sera pas
complètement fou au niveau de la
collection mais ça me permettra quand
même de venir récupérer des mails vous
connecter un peu bon voilà ça dépend une
fois de plus de là où vous êtes de la
couverture c'est pas magique ça n'a pas
créé
le réseau qui n'existe pas chez ce match
marque en force que je peux avoir d'un
côté avec la 4g plus et de ce côté avec
l'adsl très clairement avec la 4g plus
je suis arrivée chez moi ça devrait bien
évidemment de chez vous de votre qualité
de votre casier compagnie chez moi en
download j'étais à 34,97 megabit par
seconde au niveau de la 4g plus comme ce
que sur l'adsl gta linotte 023 megabit
par seconde
bon on fait quasiment x 3 c'est quand
même relativement énorme tandis qu'en
not alone pour envoyer par exemple -
mais vidéo et bien au niveau de la 4g
plus été à 2084 laisse que des volets
dsl je suis à 0,79 doc a quand même un
gap ça améliore significativement pour
moi la capacité de télécharger deux
plots d'aimer vidéo ça va beaucoup plus
vite j'ai du temps de la productivité
donc ça c'est vraiment intéressant donc
une fois de plus les couvertures est
bonne ça ira si non mais ça sera un peu
moins bon pour nous à configurer ces
petites bêtes vous allez dans votre
ordinateur ici adresse ip 180 268 1.1
bout un grand classique et vous avez
accès à tout vous vous connecter d'abord
vous avez un autre pas sa rentrée
il faut ensuite lire déverrouiller votre
carte sim une fois que vous l'avez lille
héroïque avec votre petit code ça
fonctionne mais ensuite vous voulez vous
avez accès à thouars c'est très simple
ici pour devenir un petit peu tout
régler vous avez une vision globale de
votre accès internet qui connecté ici en
4g d'année vous le voyez là et vous le
voyez aussi sur le bâti la la c'est
indiqué facile voyez bien 4g on voit
qu'il est connecté donc là ça fonctionne
on peut vous dire configuré avec un
réseau wan mèche de tp link sans apparat
dans quelques temps pour venir créer un
réseau wifi may et flexible vous verrez
on en reparle dans quelques temps on va
venir tester ça c'est vachement
intéressant bon après contrôle parental
réseau d'invités pourquoi pas on peut le
faire si on le souhaite et ce tous très
intéressante vous allez dans avancé il
venait de fouiller tout en bas il ya pas
mal de possibilités pas mal de petits
réglages pourrait fermer pouvait bien
notamment venir configurer un vpn et
s'apprend coup ça peut être vraiment à
la sont si vous utilisez des peines pour
venir sécuriser votre connexion internet
bon mais pas mal de petites possibilités
que ce soit au niveau de la navigation
sur un navigateur internet ou en créant
une application qui existe qui s'appelle
tp lite et earth et soeurs et or j'ai
pas exactement le bon accent mais qui
fonctionne également
vous pouvez devenir brancher une console
une télé cap car un pc tout ce que vous
pouvez tout ce qui va se brancher
directement ici derrière vous pouvez
jusqu'à 4 ça marche bien tout le reste
en wifi et jusqu'à 64 appareils
simultanément pc tablette smartphone
beaucoup de choses même de la sécurité à
l'intérieur si vous avez une maison il
de temps en temps alors vous avez la
cage et ça fonctionne et bien des
pouvoirs à brancher vos caméras de
sécurité pour pouvoir vraiment contrôler
ce qui se passe chez vous à distance
pourquoi pas aussi réglé chauffage
imaginez vous faites partie vous venez à
la maison que les week-ends et bien vous
pouvez venir paramétrer votre chauffage
convenir l'activé que vous l'activez est
affilié pas mal de possibilités de quel
usage est en tout cas je suis ça
vraiment cool en plus de ça vous avez
une prise en charge des bandes multi
opérateurs orange sfr free bouygues
vous êtes quand même relativement
tranquille quel que soit votre opérateur
et même si plus tard vous souhaitez en
changer ça fonctionne garanti trois ans
plutôt bien efficace ça vous solutionne
pas mal de problèmes ça dépend
évidemment de votre cas de figure mais
je vous dis une fois de plus il ya
beaucoup de cas les usages intéressant
donc ça c'est plutôt qu un produit qui
marque bien évidemment sur windows mac
linux sans souci est qu'on peut trouver
aux alentours de 130 euros un peu plus
un peu moins en ce moment voir un petit
peu moins sur les fêtes de fin d'année
ça c'est cool produit vraiment cool qui
vous solutionne pas mal de soucis dites
moi vous si vous utilisez un routeur 4g
on vient vous solutionner les problèmes
d'internet à la maison est ce que ce
produit là pourrait vous intéresser
archers m r 600 de tp link part qui va
tout ça en commentaire à nous on se
retrouve dès demain parce qu'on va avoir
plein de choses à se dire sur la tête
latex ne s'arrête pas sur ce je vous
embrasse
et bien je vous dis à très très vite
mintya août